and now great moments in unintended
consequences part 1 Osborne reef the
eros 1972 the problem too many old tires
piling up in landfills the solution
dumped over 2 million of them off the
coast of Florida create an artificial
reef for marine life sounds like a great
idea with the best of intentions what
could possibly go wrong it turns out
tires are round and they roll becoming
uncontrollable wrecking balls that
destroy the natural coral nearby some
scientists believe the rubber is also
the king toxins into the environment one
thing is for sure cleaning up this mess
will take years across the millions of
dollars and even require help from the
military part two corn ethanol subsidies
word got out corn ethanol is cheaper
cleaner renewable and it will reduce our
dependence on foreign oil soon after a
long term legislation to subsidize it
and mandate its consumption sounds like
a great idea with the best of intentions
what could possibly go wrong so so so
many things soil erosion widespread
deforestation rising food prices rising
gas prices massive water requirements
pollution from fertilizer and pesticides
and the fact that throughout the entire
production cycle ethanol produces more
greenhouse gases than regular gasoline
and according to scientists at Cornell
University and the University of
California making one gallon of corn
ethanol requires 1.29 gallons of fossil
fuel all this at a cost of 7 billion
dollars a year even Al Gore recently
admitted the subsidies were a mistake
part three legislation that requires
health insurance companies which offer
child-only policies to accept all
children regardless of pre-existing
medical conditions sounds like a great
idea with the best of intentions what
could possibly go wrong
the real problem here is that medical
care costs money this sort of
legislation encourages people to hold
off on paying for health insurance until
it's needed driving a premiums for all
customers who are in turn encouraged to
drop their coverage now you have an
adverse selection death spiral with
results that are just as bad as that
sounds so instead of committing economic
suicide those companies completely
stopped issuing child-only policies and
now even healthy children can't get
coverage which might be funny if it
wasn't just sad this has been great
moments in unintended consequences good
intentions bad results
[Music]